sound this a mechanical wave when you
are in a concert and the music is very
loud you can feel your chest vibrating
basically we are taking advantage of
this force manipulating ultrasonic sound
waves to make the particle levitate each
of this element is a tiny loudspeaker
and we control very finely what they are
playing if you are careful you can make
all the waves to reach the particle at
the same time and make it levitate it
was well known even since the 30s that
acoustic waste could create a radiation
forces and even from you know 30 years
ago people have been using a cost
acoustic forces to levitate things the
real novelty of this work is that we
only need one side a device with only
one side previously you need two devices
so the levitated particle had to be
enclosure by the acoustic elements here
for instance imagine that you wanted to
levitate something inside your body so
with this you could apply a one-sided
device it on your body as you will do
with an ultrasound scanner would be any
particle that it's inside your body and
you can manipulate it without the
necessity to get any card intervention
so the device it's mainly composed of
ultrasonic loudspeakers this computer is
running a simulation that tells the
driver wall what kind of sounds should
be play at each speaker by controlling
the sound for each loudspeaker
we can move the particular round
instance now the computer is calculating
what must be played on its loudspeaker
to levitate the particle at the target
point and then sending these waves to
the loudspeakers the acoustic field is
the amplitude of the sound like how
powerful or if we could hear it how loud
it would be the particle will be trapped
in regions of very low amplitude
surrounded by high amplitude the main
way of visualizing the acoustic field is
through to the acoustic slice of the
amplitude which is nice and it's the
common way but is not very insightful
especially if you need more information
about the 3d field so another technique
that we have developed here
it's the isosurfaces and we can observe
the 3d acoustic field as if it were an
hologram currently we are able to
levitate all extreme bits and they have
a DME diameter around two millimeters
but we hope to levitate something much
smaller for instance cells inside your
living body are also much bigger like a
soccer football
you